- [Mark] All right, Dino.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Dino, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I'm originally from San Diego.
- [Mark] San Diego, and uh
tell me about your family.
You had both your parents
- [Dino] I had both my
parents in my life, um
My mother,
I stayed with my mother most of the time.
And my Dad was in and out,
and um, there was 6 of
us; 3 boys, and 3 girls.
And I'm the oldest of the boys, so.
- [Mark] How would you
describe your childhood?
- My childhood, um
As the typical black
person's childhood, you know.
Trials and tribulations,
mother and dad fighting.
Domestic violence, police being called, um
Trying to protect my mom, and trying to
you know, hustle everyday
to provide for the family.
- [Mark] And how far did you go in school?
- Oh, I did excellent in School.
Went to Hoover High,
graduated with a 3.58 GPA.
Um, went to college too, for 2 years.
- [Mark] Oh, you did?
- Yeah
- [Mark] Right
- And how did you get into the game?
- I got in the game
at a young age, um I think I was
around 13, I had, uh, a pimp
pulled up on me, and said
"Hey, I want you to serve my hoe"
I said, "Serve yo hoe?
What does that mean?"
He sent a uh, a coach
car to come pick me up.
And, it was a Lincoln.
I said "OK"
Car came and got me, and driver
went to the hotel, like
"Yeah, I need you to
serve this, serve this chick."
And I'm like "Wha, what
part of the game is this?"
He's like "I'm gonna
pay you for your time.
Just serve her."
So basically, he wanted me to go
ahead and break his
bitch, his main bitch that
I'd been having eyes on.
And from there, I broke
the bitch, He paid me.
Then she was my bitch, and
it's been going ever since.
- [Mark] So your job was to
- Break a bitch
- And, break means, what?
- [Dino] Fuck the shit out of them,
break that hoe down, and break the bitch.
- [Mark] So, I mean.
Tell, tell me what the, the basic dynamic
- Basically, I guess,
she was out-of-pocket,
some way, shape, form, or fashion, and
- [Mark] Is this punishment?
- Punishment, basically is what it was.
While he sat there and got high,
While I fucked his main bitch.
And he paid me to do it.
I thought that was excellent.
- [Mark] I mean alo, a lot of the
relationship between a
pimp and a prostitute
seems to be
almost like, mind control.
- [Dino] You're absolutely right.
Once you get a hold of
their mind, you know
Where, where there's security, they
feel secure with us, you know.
We provide things that, they're lacking of
or that, they didn't have growing up.
- [Mark] Is it, ih, Also it seems to me
this is just my guess that
a lot of these women came from
abusive rela, uh, childhoods
where, where they, they were molested as
sexual abuse or, physical abuse or
dad was out of the picture, some, some
form of disfunction in their childhood
so now, as an adult,
they find this lifestyle
provides a similar
- Comfort
- [Mark] It's, it's
- Right
- [Mark] it's what they are used to
- You're absolutely right
- [Mark] So you get these, you get these,
these, these guys that are just using you
- [Dino] Right
- [Mark] The tricks
- Right
- [Mark] And then you get these pimps
that are taking advantage of you, and
using you
and that, is what you are used to.
- [Dino] You're right
- [Mark] It's sad, but
- [Dino] It is, but it's life
you know, we we're dealt cards of
in life, it's like playing cards.
You're deala, dealt a hand, and
It's up to you to make a choice.
- [Mark] But it's, you know, so many
people want to blame the pimps though
you taking advantage of these girls
and what I'm hearing, over and over again
- [Dino] They chose us.
- [Mark] The women are
choosing these guys to
- [Dino] You're absolutely right.
- [Mark] To treat them the way they
- [Dino] Absolutely right.
- [Mark] They are being treated, and
you give them a way out?
- [Dino] Man
- [Mark] They don't want it.
- [Dino] They don't want it.
You're absolutely right
I says you want to go to school?
What do you want to do?
You wanna, you know
get a career? Do something different?
They say no.
- [Mark] And they might complain, that
they can't get out, and they, you know
They're, they're
not saving money, and all that, but
You don't see them making the
serious effort to get out.
- No, you don't, you don't.
- [Mark] What I see is a
serious effort to bring Daddy money.
- That's what it is,
bring, bring me my money.
- [Mark] Yeah, so your arrangement is
they bring you how much of the money?
- [Dino] Um, it depends, you know.
1000,
only 3 girls working, but
- [Mark] So, they are not bringing
you 100%?
- Of course, yeah, they
better bring me 100%
or I'm gonna give them um, half, 50%
They want 100% of pimpin',
or 50% of pimpin'?
- [Mark] Oh, I see, so they do bring
- Yeah, they gotta bring
100%, to the table.
- [Mark] And what do they get out of that?
- They get stability, they get a roof
over their head, they
get clothes, they get
money for their pockets
if they want to go get
they nails done, feet done.
- [Mark] Is there some form of protection
that you provide too?
- Of course, at all times.
- [Mark] How do you, how do you do that?
- Either, I'm
If they are uncomfortable with the trick,
they give me a call,
I'm outside the room, you know.
We have little codes, we use.
And I'm in the room within 15 seconds,
I'm in the do'.
You know, I'm in the dough.
- [Mark] It's, it's it's a dangerous life,
for the girls, right?
- It is a dangerous life, but it's also
yeah, yeah it is 'cause ain't no telling
every car they jump in, you don't
know if there's last time
you are gonna see them
what's on the trick's mind,
or what he could do.
- [Mark] It's a crazy life.
- It is
- [Mark] Its a really
crazy lifestyle, 'cause
as an outside, as a square
- Right
- [Mark] I hear the
girls tell these stories
like you're just getting,
you're risking your life, every night
- Right
- [Mark] You're getting beat up regularly.
- [Mark] You're giving away
a lot of your money
- You're right
- [Mark] If not, all of it
- [Mark] You're not saving.
- You're right
- [Mark] And, it's just
like, so (shallow chuckle)
- (brief laughter)
- [Mark] You just shake your heads
head and go 'Man'
- Right
- [Mark] And they can't see,
they can't see a way out.
- Has to do with sss, psychology, you know
Psychological, there is something
wrong with the individual.
Or, that's what they're used to
so that's the comfort zone, and
that's what they want to continue
to happen to them.
- [Mark] Yeah. It's like
that, that, that's what they want.
- That's exactly what they want.
- Cause you give them
something better they
- Yes, yes.
- [Mark] They don't
know what to do with it.
- You're absolutely right.
- [Mark] So , lear, learning this, was
this a natural thing for you,
or you learned it as young man?
- Um. I don't know.
I used to sell lollipops at school
So suckers, 25 cent suckers and uh
um, Bubbalicious bubble
gum, 50 cents a pack.
I always had my way with the,
with the ladies, you know
Right now, I've got a wife, a girlfriend,
a mistress, and a side bitch, on the side.
But they all know about each other.
Either, you're going to get with
with the program or not, you know?
- [Mark] You're honest with everybody
- I gotta be, I gotta be today.
- [Mark] It'd be too stressful, they kinda
- Man! Yeah!
- [Mark] You've been arrested for this?
- I've never been
arrested for, for this um
In the fast money, you know San Diego,
Tijuana was right there, so
Anything I want, I go get
- [Mark] So you work
out of San Diego or LA?
- I'm from San Diego, but I live in LA?
- [Mark] You live in LA now.
- Yeah
- [Mark] And your girls
are different races?
- Yeah
- [Mark] What's, do you have
- Caucasian, snow bunnies,
is, is the go-getters.
They don't come with as
much problems, you know?
They go out, get the money, they bring
bring me the money, and
everything is everything.
- [Mark] So, fewer
headaches with white girls?
- Shh, fewer headaches?
You hear so many stories
there's too many problems
behind the money, you know?
It doesn't add up, you know?
You're out there for 5 hours,
you only got $100.
The other one is out there for 2 hours
she got $1000, like what's going on?
- [Mark] So white girls
bring in more money?
- Yeah, yeah
There's a higher market out there.
- [Mark] And then, as far as the
customers, the clients
do the girls steer away
from certain races?
- They try to stay away
from African Americans.
Many, some of say their
dick is too big, and
they're just too much uh, aggressive, um
you know
- [Mark] I hear a lot of the girls
saying "they are always
playing games, they are always"
- Right, right
- [Mark] They're tryin'
- Saying they got the money,
but they aint got money.
- [Mark] They're tryin'
- Right, right
- [Mark] Is sex part of the
scene with your girls?
- Sometimes, you know, they get
if they do good, they get treated good.
You know
When you got, sex with a prostitute is
different because
a pimp could go as far
as he want up in a bitch
but a trick, she's only going to
let him go so far, so
You now, pleasure is for the pimp, but
It's, it's, it's just life.
It's just weird shit.
It's really really weird.
- [Mark] You ever day a left?
- Yeah, I have.
Um, to my second baby mama.
Um, 14 years,
3 beautiful kids, um
I was a square, I was a 9-5,
working off of Wilshire Boulevard.
Working on Slawson and Western.
You know, 9 to 5 and 7 to 11.
Two jobs, was like a machine.
But when you don't get
appreciated at home,
or they take your kindness for weakness
Then, you seek attention, and you
You know, you build up this defense
and then you, you use it on somebody else
you try to manip, manipulate somebody else
and get what you want,
or what you're yearning for,
or, what you're craving for.
- [Mark] What qualities do you
look for in a girl?
- [Dino] Qualities I look for in a girl
is somebody who's smart, you know?
Good looking doesn't necessary have
to play a big factor, you know.
She can be 500 lbs, you know, but
She has a sweet personality, um.
(twin police sirens wailing)
You know, lips is a, is a plus,
and the face, the face gotta be A1.
Cause if the body's not altogether
long enough the face is together,
then, she gots potential.
(police sirens wailing)
- [Interviewer] And what happens when,
when your girls get out of line?
Do you ever have to?
- [Dino] I'm not abusive
I seen that growing up too much
in the streets, and in the game, um
Punishment,
somewhat, but, it's nothing drastic.
I'd never slap a bitch, you know.
- [Interviewer] How about drugs?
- [Dino] I don't do them.
- [Mark] What about the girls?
- [Dino] They don't need to do them.
If they do them, they don't let me know.
- [Mark] It seems like just
to do this, you would need to
be drunk or high.
- [Dino] You're absolutely right.
An to get that fix, or that motivation,
or that courage, or that strength
to go out there and go
do it, you're right.
- [Mark] I have a hard time imagining a
girl can't just do this, straight, without
- [Dino] Right
some kind of chemical
- [Mark] Without getting depressed,
or something like that.
- [Dino] You're right.
- [Mark] What's more important to you,
love, or money?
- That's a good ass question.
You know, money, is more important than
love right now, cause without
money, you have nothin'
you can't do nothin'
- [Mark] What personality trait
helps you
excel at this?
- Charisma, and my gift of gab.
Just to be able to speak to somebody,
talk to somebody, and break 'em down
or make them feel comfortable with me.
- [Mark] Attraction is a big
part of it for the female.
- Of course
- [Mark] She has to be
attracted to the pimp
- Of course, of course.
- [Mark] And what's the
craziest thing you've seen?
- The craziest thing I've seen
was
a prostitute
getting shot by a trick, with a .357
Shot her in the ass
yeah
I don't know, maybe she was in
his pockets, or something happened.
Something happened in the car.
Before I knew it, he pulled out a gun and
she was bent over, and he
shot her in the ass, so
That's about it.
- [Mark] So, stealing from
the tricks is part of the game.
- Part of the game, yeah.
Catch him with his pants down to his
ankles, you know, she's in the pockets
and then, the money goes, you know.
It's, it's weird, it's weird.
It's fucking crazy.
- [Mark] It's a weird little
world, cause everybody's out
- Yes.
- [Mark] For their own best
interest, right?
- You're absolutely right.
- [Mark] The tricks, the pimps.
- [Mark] Everybody is using everybody.
- Everybody
- [Mark] Everybody is taking advantage
- Everybody, that's what it is.
Exactly what it is.
- [Mark] How many kids do you have?
I got 4.
- [Mark] How would you feel
if one, you have daughters?
I got 2 daughters.
I got an 18 year old and a 13 year old.
- [Mark] How would you feel if
you saw the 18 year old out on
the blade one day?
- You know what, um.
It's funny that you said that because
my oldest daughter, she's wild now.
Like, I met her mom off the party line,
I hit it one time, 9 months later
she called me and told
me the bay was mine.
So everything
that she's doing, I don't agree of
of her lifestyle, but
all I can do is support
her, and have her back.
That's all I can do.
- [Mark] And what's the most
important lesson you've learned?
- Life is about choices, okay?
You have a choice either to
partake in what's going on in the
environment, or
you can be a square, and just, you
know, just do right.
Ain't nothing wrong with doing right.
I swear to God.
If I could go back 10 or 20 years,
back, and I can go and change my life
and do it over again, I would.
- [Mark] You'd, You'd live
a square life?
(mouth droning)
The square life was all right.
Going to Instanidas, surfing, beach
you know, Starbucks, just doing
normal routine shit, good shit.
Living life.
Hiking.
- [Mark] Better karma?
- Yeah (childish chuckling) yeah.
- [Mark] There's a lot
of different styles
- Okay
- [Mark] To being a pimp, right?
- You're absolutely right
- [Mark] There's Gorilla pimps
there's
- There is!
- [Mark] There's
There's guys that sweet talk the girls
there's, tell, tell me about that.
Which, which one are you?
- I'm suave, or Casanova, you know? Um
I just make 'em, I break them down,
make them feel comfortable.
Then I tell 'em walla wallama wallamma
bout, you know?
Either, they either gonna choose
up, or they aint.
- [Mark] But then, but then,
all these different styles, all
kinda go into the umbrella of
mind-control.
- You're absolutely right. (chuckling)
You're right.
- [Mark] So, no matter
what your style, you're still like
- Long enough you can control
that mind, you got it.
You got it.
- [Mark] And how does
that make you feel at night?
When you're, when you're by yourself
you're going to bed, you okay
with the fact that that's how
you make your living?
- [Dino] No, but I'm comfortable
with it, for the time being.
Until another opportunity opens
it's doors for me, then I'll,
I'll venture off, but right now,
I'm okay.
- [Mark] All right, Dino, thank
you so much for sharing your story
- Hey, I appreciate you.
- [Mark] Wish you the best of Luck.
- All right, thanks a lot.
- [Mark] Bye now, thank you.
- [Dino] umhm